[Music]
double eviction what were you thinking
when you got put on that block you know
as much as I want to argue with it
because of course I wanted to stay in
there it wasn't a bad choice Chris the
reality is had I gotten through this one
I think there is an endurance
competition they're doing right now I
would have done
most likely really well in that one and
look had a much much really good chance
much better chance for sure the mean
here got to go all the way to the end so
it was a bummer but there's also a sense
relief to go back to the real world
as fun as that was I miss talking to my
own fans when I go see my girl my family
it's gonna be a nice big game move from
Rossa to get you out does that make you
think differently about who you're gonna
vote for in the end or well I guess it
depends on who's at the end you know
Omarosa has been an absolute doll as a
person to me she's been wonderful fun to
talk to but I'm not sure that she ever
really had much of a strategy
respectfully she caused chaos by lying
to everybody in the house all the time
and that doesn't really it was never
smart no way did I really feel that that
really benefited her because nobody
trusts her any person she kind of has
now is re because brandy told a lie is
getting a fusing for those you at home
who don't know what's been going on in
the house so look I think that it was a
last-second gametime decision for her
she really wanted Ross Marissa out but
then by putting me up she knew I was
gonna go so hey definitely a big target
been complimented since people would say
in that day one but we'll see I don't
think Oh Marissa will make it all the
way to the end okay right now if you had
to call it who's that final two I mean
Ross has played a wonderful game the
social games not going to matter much
now it's more competitions ari is in the
best shape of everybody left right now
so maybe Ross and Ari up I'm rooting for
my boy mark everybody now you got to
deliver a pretty sweet message for you
to Brandi a sayonara from me oh did you
guys play that one yes you got two
fantastic but then is it a little
bittersweet / cruel that you get to go
out the door right after her no no I
went out before her it's all good I'm
content you know look it I was pegged as
the first one out the door from the
moment I walked in there and it was you
know bit of a bummer until I decided hey
this is a game anything can happen and I
went and decided I'm gonna flip this
house
and obviously things had to fall into
place but from then on it was kind of a
fun game but I've always been a big
target
I just it was always in the back of my
head that if I'd go out at any point
it's okay to me was a win being on the
show and frankly being a part of every
episode which I have been and will be
back on Sunday is really just wonderful
so thanks guys the opportunity and I'm
going back to my regular life I have
nothing to claim about I like it
positive to the end so no regrets about
this experience anything you would have
done differently you know look I'm sure
everybody's gonna be a Monday Morning
Quarterback right and my morning coach I
say it and say well if you did this he
did that I did everything pretty darn
well considering the odds were very much
stacked against me from beginning
Omarosa I didn't expect her to get this
HOH I mean frankly she beat me fair and
square I thought I was gonna have it and
the way that things fell then Ross got
the veto the only thing that would have
changed out is if I'd really dug deeper
into that deal that Omarosa wanted to
make with mark and I I never really said
no because I've tried to play it cool
but I definitely didn't agree to it was
very clear I was sticking to my Final
Four and and being a man of my word so
had I changed that maybe I'd still be in
the game but then I would have been no
longer a man of my word which I'm proud
to say like I played the game with class
and tact and I'm out early because of it
but I'm also so Who I am so I can't be
mad at that yeah you stayed true to who
you are the second you went in that door
halfway through
[Music]